[Musik]
der landstraße alltag also einen
kreislauf klick können aber den ausgang
konsumieren ohne an die ich merke für
mich das werde dazu führen dass ich
meinen teil sie vor dem sinnlosen konsum
sondern eine bewegung nach fürth
trotzdem ist es schön ins quartier eine
herzensangelegenheit
ich bin goller ich bin 27
mit der stadt zürich oder lange straße
machen wir mal zu den ursprünglich
niedrig lag minimal the waste heißt für
mich dass ich endlich stufen alles
verzichten was unnötig ist spricht ich
auf mich und plastik ich brauche
fröhlich zum im griff
ich habe am anfang meine praktische
sache wie zahnpasta oder der basler
anstatt das ist eine konventionelle
zahnpasta und kokosnussöl und aktivkohle
und kokosnussöl ich an die mikro
bakteriell und antifa und megafon für
alles und aktivkohle dazu ganz viel aber
sie fühlt
[Musik]
für das gehäuse ist wunderbar schminke
das machen wir das packen so mysteriös
kokosnussöl schmeckt ja aber meine
gewisse punkte und jetzt hast du heißt
ich so ist aber es gott ganz nahe dran
oder geringer ist das verhindert dass
sich bakterien bilden sind und auch die
180 und das funktioniert industrie ob es
bekämpft eigentlich nicht im dom stinken
sondern das am anfang also durch
bakterien und stinkt es gibt natürlich
auch in sachen afrikas von der ezb vor
dass angefangen schätze dass gott
besonders jahr eine halbe sache muss
gefasst
also bevor du mit all den sachen fertig
und sich mehr am samstag strand
schwimmen vorwärts aber bei der bergtour
über und sich okay
ich habe alles offen und brings und dass
die glasserie fülle und somit also dann
kann abfall der dom in der tosa der
faust ist und wir kuscheln sich lustig
mitgliedschaft automatisch und spüli und
zucchini dafür steht ihnen durch das
glas und sind sehr revidiert aber es hat
ich habe kein abfall mehr oder nur noch
aus glas und für sich gezogen
ich möchte das nicht ein moment abfall
und vieles war da jetzt ein trainer ist
recycling abfall also das ist eigentlich
will links ab und zu gönnt man sich
linse denn so die apple
sieben mal vergessen sagt grafe oder
halte ist o'leary und th und zur
direkten art erstmals mit dem text ich
wenigstens nur ein ist nur wann dann
das ist so bodylotion vorderhand kaum
mit anderer fertig ist dann ist das auto
schon mal mit 80 euro sich jetzt
neunjährigen ich hunger habe und dann
halt die klappe liter vom regensburger
holen
aber ich habe das auto ab und total sich
wie ein gewisses zugeschnitten und das
ist okay man es war schön gibt es andere
optionen aber ich mag den stress nicht
nötig also die schönen tonnen kompost
sie schwierig wenn du so der abfall
alexis prozent ab vor dem was mir nicht
verbrenne geschickt das ist ein wurden
kompost dass niemand da
damit ist ziemlich eigentlich das nicht
gibt vor denen abzieht und das nicht mal
gang das alles mit mir machen für gavi
so wie ich zur erde wird alles andere zu
einer wird beispielsweise wenn er mit
einer lotterie machen und es steckt eine
kaste die haben dann dann gerne gesamten
geschichte der fluglinie
klickt man ruhig stellen
aber es macht also viel zeit will ich
weiß ich bin mit partnership annina hat
im klub über die nachhaltigkeit und
ethik ich gerne portion begonnen
wir denken
aber das scheint auf hunger optimieren
das machst du bist ganz klar ein exot
das weckt dies nur unter schluss hat
vergleiche mit was ich mache ich sie
hier schon einmal ganz spezielles system
als männer lässig sondern das mini
community arm oder vier insights volk
wissen wo das wirklich richtig klappen
man muss schon sehr engagiert sie damit
dass vom einen tag auf den anderen
sofort alles könnte die umsätze ich
glaube dass ein qualitätsanspruch wegen
möchten umstellen oder so schritt für
schritt ist wie einfach dass man sich
damit so selber gefordert niedrigen
erwartungen voll erfüllen
der ausspruch perfekt sondern sich die
beste option zu finden ist ziel und und
das überall machen also es gibt so viele
sachen von anderen
[Musik]
die
für den x games müsli bin
hast du da mit dem stift wenige schulen
versucht und schreibe 4 187 gramm
vermutlich daran dass so ein teil von
ihnen sterbe bakterien konsulat also den
steg zu bakterien sind noch nicht so
sensibilisiert darum dass es unmöglich
war und sechseinhalb meter der uvs
betriebe so
wenn ich mit ich glaube unsere zero race
zwar recht von mir sommer aber wo ein
wille ist ist auch ein weg
irgendwie sogar fußball kompromiss maker
aber ich muss mir gedanken da nicht
machen weil ich kann glaube israel steht
auf dem ganzen weg so möglichst wenig
verschwand ich bin ich da recht nach der
parade wo sich lebens vorbild ist die
zero race klargemacht 100 programm
natron die diese geschichte studiert und
sich hin zu machen dass löw das ist
recht lässig also ich denke dass man im
herbst wird gewöhnt hoch war bitter im
glas
ich glaube finanziell in mischtechnik
und zwar für eine unfähigkeit
konsumierten stil lebensmittelkauf und
jetzt hat sich das resultat konsumieren
mega wenig kleider und lebensmittel
definitiv
[Musik]
ich bin da märz umfasst muss um zero ist
das heißt forschung sondern mir geht es
darum möglichst wenig verschwendet
stattfindet ich mache jetzt mal zehn
nach der tat so dass organisiert
[Musik]
si
es ist immer wieder schön zum produkt
und vielleicht noch nicht kennt und
spannend sind kaum vorstellen kann
[Musik]
marcel und aktive rolle
si
nein nein jetzt aber anstatt also mal
irgendwie am meisten fällt das ist das
nur geht jetzt verlangt rekordmarke
wurde und jetzt serviert punkte
wenn ich mir den berg vorstelle plastik
30 und ich benutze müsst zum zuge und
ständig zwischen
und im stil und ungerecht jährige sich
das ist aber dass bezug sei das noch
alles lieber oder
unter verhallt da kann
fällt ganz viel mit glück
mit stil und mit kurzen rot ist eine
lösung in sicht
natürlich interessieren das durch die
stadt worms habe den zug aus politik
sport
helmes war ferienzeit wurde sicher
klären plastiktröte wobei man und herren
fußball pokalspiel haben zur sache muss
man einmal verletzt
während ich bin herum
das sechste element
ich glaube dass metro werde die zukunft
flüssige gesetz finde und das jetzt
schon mit geht wo der brennenden fähre
und wo da interessiert sind und lässiger
aktiv suchen
das zeigt ja eigentlich das mal
hoffentlich bald
ich glaube bin
da